hello and welcome to the take with
safety Ridge live at nine here in the
heart of Westminster now you might
remember last March Ukraine's president
zelenski addressed the British
Parliament by video link well today he
went one better and powerfully spoke to
MPS and Lords in person in the historic
setting of Westminster Hall were nearly
a year on from his first address and the
war is still raging and president
zielinski is still asking for more
support from the West well today he met
the king and the PM and he lobbied for
British fighter jets to be sent to
Ukraine the government here seemed to
leave the door open to that something
that Russia said would have consequences
for the whole of Europe we'll bring his
takes from all sides over the next 60
minutes
we know Russia will lose
and we we really know the victory the
victory will change the world
well there were staring words in the
Palace of Westminster and then that plea
for jets
and I appeal to you and the world was
simple and yet most important words
combat aircrafts for Ukraine
wings for freedom
later president zielinski met the king
at Buckingham Palace but before that the
Prime Minister led the House of Commons
in pledging the UK support for Ukraine
this house in this country Will Stand
United with the with Ukraine until we
ensure the defeat of Vladimir Putin's
unprovoked unsanctioned aggression and
that we will make sure that Ukraine is
not only Victorious but that we bring
peace to its people
well party allegiances were put to one
side in prime minister's questions as
you just saw and the leader of the
opposition was no less Resolute in his
support for Ukraine
we in this house have a duty to stand on
the shoulders of giants who came before
us and support Ukraine's Fight For
Freedom Liberty and victory we'll look
back at a historic day here in
Westminster and try and work out what
comes next as the UK supports Ukraine in
its defense against the Russian invasion
so on the program this evening we'll be
talking to the policing Minister Chris
philp we'll also speak to laborers
Jonathan Ashworth the shadow work and
pensions secretary
plus I'm looking forward to this in
particular we'll talk to the Ukrainian
MP Kira Reddick and much more besides on
the take
[Music]
good evening well as you can imagine it
has been quite a day here in Westminster
as president zielinski surprise visit
was center stage and party rivalries
unusually it took a back seat Well after
that display of unity at Prime
Minister's questions president zelenski
spoke to both houses of Parliament in
the Magnificent medieval setting of
Westminster Hall
we know Russia will lose
and we we really know the victory the
victory will change the world and this
will be a change that the world has long
needed
United Kingdom
is marching with us towards the most I
think the most important victory of our
lifetime it will be a victory over the
very idea of the war
after we went together any aggressor it
doesn't matter big or small will know
what awaits him if he attacks
International order
any aggressor
any aggressor who will try to push the
bandaras by force who will inflict
destruction and Death on other peoples
who will try to endure his dictatorship
at the ex at the expense of other
people's blood in criminal and
unprovoked Wars as the Kremlin does any
aggressor is going to lose
yeah some really powerful words there
from the president of Ukraine and later
the focus became the practicalities of
War as Mr zelenski spoke alongside the
prime minister in front of a British
tank and asked for more support
including in the air
I would like to say that this day has
become very fruitful and I'm grateful to
a prime minister for understanding our
needs and for his helpful advice and for
the decisions that are truly helping our
Ukrainian Warriors to become stronger
I'm also grateful to his majesty for the
opportunity to have a meeting and
conversation with him and I'm grateful
to all of the members of the British
Parliament who today during my address
clearly showed that Great Britain will
never betray their Brave Spirit I'm also
grateful to everyone in the United
Kingdom who was today standing with
Ukrainian Flags in London and we saw
that we noticed as we were passing by
and thank you for your support and today
it is very clear that we are standing
together with Great Britain together
with the Prime Minister we signed
declaration of unity a document that
truly records principles of our
interaction and mutual support
let's bring in our Deputy political
editor at Sam Coates now and Sam it
really did feel like a momentous day uh
didn't it I think it was just the second
time that President zelenski's left
Ukraine since the outbreak of the war
and here he is on British saw talking to
British champaigns that's right uh 24
hours ago we had no idea that what
happened today was going to take place
yet first thing this morning we found
out that president zelinski was making
the 1500 mile trip to Westminster to
address both houses of Parliament spend
time with Rishi sunak the Prime Minister
hold a press conference and it really
was something quite special I thought
that the speech by president zelinski on
the steps of Westminster Hall in the
beaming sunlight through the stained
glass window was the best piece of
oratory I can remember since becoming a
political reporter about 17 years ago he
managed to reach not only for historical
Illusions but also really into the
British psych divided good from Evil
making it clear that there's historical
precedent for why we should stand by the
people of Ukraine we did so in World War
II you should do so today he talked
about his personal connection with
Churchill and he came with one ask
Sophie it was a very clear ask he said
he wanted fighter jets he even presented
Lindsey Hoyle speaker of the houses of
the House of Commons with a fighter jet
helmet to ham to hammer this point home
saying that he wanted Freedom yet later
in the day when Rishi sunak appeared
alongside president zielinski at a press
conference the question turned to him
are you going to give him those Jets and
the answer was not quite clear you say
it's not clear and to be honest this is
how I'm feeling a little bit right
the door to it but I can't tell if
that's because yeah they are going to do
it they're just working out the
logistics or if they're just kicking it
into the long grass trying to say one
words but not actually making a decision
on it if I'm being completely honest it
was a rather frustrating press
conference to watch because journalists
after journalists asked are you going to
give them the Jets and he found lots of
ways of slightly parrying the question
and by the end he was clearly frustrated
he was saying well of course you need to
train fighter pilots and we're doing
that but that takes years so maybe
that's a problem and some jets are owned
by lots of different countries and also
Jets aren't the answer he actually
started and I'm going to use this word
advisory mansplaining the person
standing next to him say when President
zelinski asked for jet what he really
needed was a whole load of short-term
equipment to help fight the war in the
near term and
he didn't have a clear answer that could
have soared above it actually
Britain has a very proud story to tell
on Ukraine it has been a leader against
opposition from European countries and
the U.S president in terms of
encouraging the world to give to Ukraine
in terms of armaments yet
where she said that didn't quite convey
that in the press conference today and I
just think that kind of communication
difficulty will worry some of his own
party I want to talk to you more about
the UK efforts with Ukraine and later in
the program but for now thank you very
much uh Sam so that was Sam's take a
little earlier I spoke to the policing
Minister Chris philp and really was
trying to get to the bottom of the
question that we were just asking there
are the Jazz coming
so you were in Westminster Hall when the
president of Ukraine addressed MPS it
must have been quite a moment it was as
soon as I heard president zlenski was
going to be coming to Westminster Hall I
kind of canceled everything in my diary
and and went straight there Westminster
Hall is an incredibly historic place
it's there's been a hall there for 900
years and over the centuries some
extraordinary historic things have have
happened there from the the trial of uh
King Charles the first uh all kinds of
things have happened in that place uh
more recently great Statesmen have
addressed both houses of Parliament
people like Nelson Mandela and Barack
Obama and I think when people look back
at president zielinski's address today
to both houses of Parliament and many
other hundreds of people as well they
will look back on that as something that
is similarly historic uh the the war
leader the leader of a a nation who's
very survival is being threatened by an
aggressor you know coming to speak to
one of the oldest democracies in the
world we're doing everything we can to
support them it was quite a I think it
was quite a special moment that he came
Diamond spoke to us in that way I think
I'm certainly going to remember it for
the rest of my life and I suspect other
people who are there will as well I
guess we don't know how the story of the
Ukraine war ends I mean it was very
clear wasn't it it was only President
zelinski's second visit out if Ukraine
since the beginning of the war he knew
why he was here he was here because he
was asking for jets is he going to get
them well and president zlinski has
obviously asked the West for military
Support over the last year and the
United Kingdom has been leading Europe
in providing that support I mean most
the Challenger tanks the missiles
um the air defense systems 2.3 billion
pounds worth last year in the same this
year and now the Jets and I think the
Prime Minister has said today that he
has tasked the our defense secretary Ben
Wallace with looking into how we can
help with that request nothing is off
the table I take it from that that there
is no objection in principle because
otherwise he wouldn't have asked the
defense secretary to go and look into
this there are obviously
some questions around training because
the training to fly one of these Jets
can take a while and yes right yeah well
it can't it can't in ordinary times take
years that's that's right um but the
fact that the primary app prime minister
Rishi sunak has asked to defend the UK
defense secretary
um to look into this I think is a pretty
clear signal of intent I don't get it
right because I take you how you read
this right but I genuinely am a bit
confused I can't work out if he says
he's going to look at this he's asked
Ben Wallace to have a look at it I can't
work out if that is kicking it into the
long grass or if that means we are
actually going to send Jets can you
clarify well I think it's it
demonstrates serious intent right you
don't get what does that means I'm not
sure what that means I think I'm clearly
sending um jets and working out the
training that would go around those is
not a like a straightforward
um exercise right these are very
complicated bits of equipment
um as you said ordinarily it takes five
years to train to fly one of these
pieces of kid so it's not
straightforward and I think what the
Prime Minister means he wants the
defense secretary
um to look at the practicalities of how
that could be made to work but the fact
he's asked him to do that suggests to me
um that there's no in principle
objection to doing it it suggests to me
that there is um serious intent but it's
got to be but it's but it's got to be
worked through in a in a proper
thoughtful way they're a genuine concern
about what this means when it comes to
the war and how Russia will see this
because you know the Russian Ambassador
at a billion said about tanks that it
was an extremely dangerous decision it
takes a conflict to a new level of
Confrontation the Kremlin have come out
to you know condemn the idea of jets as
well according to a Russian news
agencies are we concerned about what it
means would it mean an escalation the
Russians have made these kind of
comments previously we are helping a a
sovereign free Democratic country defend
themselves from an unconscionable Act of
aggression which is encounter only
finish which is included
um deliberately targeting and murdering
civilians we are perfectly within our
rights to do anything that we feel
necessary to help the ukrainians defend
themselves I personally see no in
principle reason why that shouldn't
include Jets to prevent women and
children getting getting killed which is
happening as we speak and I don't think
we should allow comments by a regime
like Putin's to deter us from doing that
we're supporting and helping a free
Democratic Nation defend themselves and
defend civilians from a barbaric attack
so does it Rose our Threat Level
um well we we've seen we've seen we've
seen the Russians employ rhetoric in the
past we're obviously always very
thoughtful about our own security
um but I think you know there is no need
for us to be
apologetic or or defensive about helping
a free Democratic Nation defend itself
so it's it's worth it it's the argument
that you would give that even if it does
increase the Threat Level from Russia
it's worth it because of the democratic
principle well I'm not sure I'm
accepting the kind of premise of the
questions I think it may be rhetorical
what I am what I am what I am saying is
that this is a free Democratic country a
European country being brutally attacked
civilians are being deliberately
targeted murdered by the Russian regime
and I think in those circumstances we
should do everything we can to help them
defend themselves and I think president
zielinski made an interesting point in
his speech today he talked about
um how he'd been to the cabinet War
rooms in the past sat in Churchill's uh
chair and he talked about how making
sure Russia does not succeed in their
murderous and illegal objectives will
that will act as actually a deterrent to
other aggressive countries that may
think about doing this kind of thing
indeed to Russia itself and actually by
helping Ukraine in their fight for their
own Survival we're actually making the
whole world a safer place because it
means aggressive regimes like Putin just
think twice or think three times or
perhaps don't do it at all when they
look over their borders at neighboring
countries so I think being being firm
and supporting Ukraine actually over to
viewed in the round makes the world
safer and one other question on Ukraine
and we've focus a lot on Jets I have to
say I my ears picked up when Russia Cena
was talking about long-range missiles
saying that actually this is what he
spent most of the time talking about
long-range missiles uh Boris Johnson
also called for them to be provided
should they be one of the Prime Minister
himself which is soon like was was clear
about the importance of doing that and
he's been actively discussing that with
president zelinski is that going to
happen today what's going to happen it's
for the Prime Minister and defense
secretary to make those kind of of
announcements it's not for me but it's
been quite clear from his comments the
Prime Minister was actively discussing
that today and again it helps the
ukrainians defend themselves against
this barbaric attack eventually attack
Russia as well we're helping Ukraine
defend themselves from this barbaric
attack and I think any Sovereign Nation
has the right to do that and I think we
have a right if anything we have a moral
G it's more than the right we have a
duty
um to help them defend themselves not
just because it's the right thing to do
because it makes the world a safer place
um now on a um I think many people like
would completely agree with the comments
that you make about the importance of
supporting Ukraine and one other issue
that I'm quite Keen to talk to you about
is that we've seen the re-emergence so
we say if you're from a boss uh Liz
trust you obviously served in her
treasury when she was prime minister it
made a appearance at pmqs too I just
want to listen to the SNP leader uh
Stephen uh Flynn and you know what's
coming
now the former prime minister won't
apologize for the damage that she has
caused so on behalf of the Tory party
will he apologized for her
I mean there is an argument that Richard
seem like shouldn't be apologizing
because he didn't serve he ran against
Liz truss he described her ideas as
fantasy economics you obviously did
serve in her cabinet would you like to
apologize well English trust actually
did Apologize at the time for the
turmoil um that occurred but since um
Richardson came to become Prime Minister
three or so months ago and the various
market indices have basically returned
to where they were before so the
currency I remember maybe even become on
your show and you have some charts on
the wall yeah
that's right and the currency had gone
from he was 113 against the dollar it
went down it's now actually up above
where it was last time I checked a week
or two ago
um above where it was um when she came
to office and the similar is true of
bond yields so that's reverted to normal
we've got
um uh GDP growth last year uh 2022 in
the UK that was higher than any other G7
country
um so I think you know we can now look
to the Future we've got a very low
unemployment um in my lifetime I'm 46 is
the lowest moment almost in my lifetime
obviously challenges with cost of living
that we need to we need to face up to
um but but I think we're in a in a good
position good place I wouldn't be doing
my job if I didn't point out other
economic indicators for showing that for
example we're still got the only G7
economy with a smaller economy than uh
pre-pandemic to talk about mortgage
rates for example which certainly
haven't returned to normal but I guess
what I'm interested in right is you know
you said there about how we've done
different interviews at different times
over the last few months which we
certainly have you know you came in here
to defend this truss you're now here
defending which you see now talking up
his Economic Policy as you did just then
I mean that's pretty tough going isn't
it do you have Whiplash well I think
something like this fall is for us and I
did support the idea of having lower
taxes clearly um but you know you've got
to have there are a couple of reasons
why that didn't wasn't accepted by the
financial markets and clearly the
financial markets did reject the
approach but that was for a number of
reasons one was there weren't um
spending reductions to fund the tax cuts
and there wasn't obr scoring so there
was a violent Market reaction that we
talked about
um at the time and that's why a
different approach was then uh was then
needed you have to deal with reality uh
as you encounter it and clearly the
markets reacted
um very badly and so
um that's why there was a change and
that's why Rishi came in and did what he
did what he did which is broadly
speaking work those numbers have now
reverted to where they were before
mortgage rates have gone up across the
world here in the UK they've basically
gone back pretty much to where they were
you know in in August or or September
before the mini budget but there is
still a lot more work to do Across the
Western World on the cost of living
inflation and so on and so forth it's
interesting you're talking about the
market reaction and mentioning the obr
because obviously Liz trusted and her
article in the Sunday Telegraph as well
she blamed a powerful economic
establishment for some of the issues she
faced she also said the office for
Budget responsibility you know the
effectively the Watchdog they kind of
Mark the government's homework if you
like she accused them of putting fiscal
policy in straight jacket and so she
disagreed with their assessment do you
think she's right on those things I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna offer a kind of
running commentary on on what Liz has
been has been saying I think what is
clear is that the approach taken
um wasn't accepted by the markets part
of that I think was the fact that there
wasn't
um an obr scoring now you can debate the
Rights and Wrongs of the obr but the the
sort of fact was that the financial
markets didn't didn't like the way it
was presenting you wouldn't put them as
part of the kind of economic
establishment then you'd say that that's
just that's a reflection of the policy I
think ultimate ultimately that the
problem was with the financial markets
right the financial markets didn't like
um the way the package was put together
um you can debate the reasons for that
but basically certainly didn't like it
and that's why a correction ended up
getting getting made in the correction
has essentially worked
um just finally um because you did
mention how you liked the ideas of lower
taxes what is your position on Lower
taxes now would you like to see taxes
come down
but I think it's got to be done in a way
that yes I would um it needs to be done
though in a way that is responsible
because we saw
what happens if the market reacts badly
so I think you know for that to happen
uh we need a certain amount of economic
growth I think the the path we're set on
uh will ultimately deliver that
um but but time will time will tell we
certainly had a I mean 20 we got all
these sort of headlines talking about uh
the UK not doing well but I mean 2021 we
had record goes from the G7 2022 last
calendar year we had record growth in
the G7
um again so and we've got very very low
unemployment indeed we're about to see
the minimum wage go up in a few weeks
Time by I think around about 10 which
will help people obviously on Lower
incomes so I hope we do get
circumstances where we can reduce taxes
but but it's got to be done in a way
obviously that is um that is responsible
and doesn't cause
um a negative Market reaction okay thank
you very much because I've got the scars
of the last one
still got the scars Chris philp uh
talking to me there a little bit earlier
about that Liz trash Premiership but of
course also about our main story tonight
on Ukraine you're watching the take
we're live here in Westminster for you
up next we'll see how that visit to the
UK has been received in Ukraine we'll go
live to Kiev to speak to an MP there
[Music]
hello welcome back live to Westminster
you're watching the take well let's
remain return to that major news of the
day shall we the historic visit by
President zielinski this is what he told
politicians of all sides earlier
living
a British Parliament two years ago I
thanked you
for delicious English tea
and I will be living
the parliament today
thanking all of you in advance
for powerful English planes
[Applause]
well that was President zielinski
speaking in Westminster and this just in
the last few minutes is a president
zelenski in Paris he has now gone to
France where he can see in their meeting
the president of France president macron
shaking hand exchanging a few words
those latest pictures from Paris a
Whistle Stop Tour by the president of
Ukraine only the second time he is left
Ukraine since the beginning of the war
and that Russian invasion over a year
ago so he's visiting some of those
crucial allies some of the countries of
course that he is hoping to get more
support and weapons from he's already
made the plea for fighter jets in the
United Kingdom I'm sure it will be a
similar ask in France as he meets there
present back on
well let's go live now to Keith we can
talk to the Ukrainian MP at Kiera
Roddick we've been lucky enough to have
Akira on the show uh before so we're
really delighted to have you today on
such a historic uh moment President
zelenski visiting both the UK and France
he's pretty clear isn't he that he wants
to see more support in the form of
fighter jets why is that so important
hello Sophie thank you so much for
having me on the show well first of all
I want to extend everything that
president zielinski said on behalf of
Ukrainian people and its gratefulness
for all the support that we received
from the United Kingdom from people of
the United Kingdom and it's very
important for us that we are not only
are asking for more support but that we
are making very clear how grateful we
are and that we will never forget it
so since the beginning of the full-scale
invasion we were asking for one thing
help us protect our skies help us to
defend ourselves against the missiles
that are coming from the ear
there is no way for people in Ukraine to
protect themselves from it we're only
accounting on the air defense systems
that are not perfect so we need this
another layer of protection and it is
fighter jets they are called fighter
jets but they are actually used to
defend the sky against the missiles that
are targeting the peaceful cities the
schools the hospitals people's homes you
probably remember just two and a half
weeks ago there was a missile attack on
a building in the nepro city where 46
people died many of them in their beds
this is what we want to protect
ourselves against this is why we need
fighter jets to be able to say to to
people in Ukraine here you may not be
scared to go to bed every night
there are ways to protect you against
those attacks so we we have had so many
unique coalitions their heavy weapon
coalitions than their analog Coalition
than the high Mars Coalition and then
the Patriot Coalition which was I think
a life-changing for uh for all of us in
Ukraine then something unspeakable
happened so the tank Coalition appeared
and now we are expecting that there
would be tanks that will allow us to
free more of our territories and finally
put the end to the war without a victory
and so what we desperately need a year
from The full-scale Envision is fighter
jet now we need the planes and uh if we
get them it will be really a game
changer in the war not on the
battlefield but in the ability of
Ukrainian people just simply live exist
you speak really powerfully about the
impact of the war and the people who've
died in their beds as you say you know
we all remember you know images from
Ukraine whether it's bombed out
playgrounds whether it's Flats lots of
flats just left in rubble in Ruins what
is your view of the British prime
minister's response to president
zielinski it wasn't clear to me whether
or not he was definitely signing up to
providing more Jets just saying that
there was no they had no problem with it
in principle
well first of all uh we all have heard
president zelenski's speech I think it
was hard to resist and absolutely hard
to say no uh to to what he was asking
um but also what we learned over the
past couple of months that when we hear
no from our allies it's just the
beginning of the conversation this is
why uh the fact that Ukrainian Pilots
will be training on the Jets is a huge
step forward for us because we know that
once we will have the trained pilots and
train Marines it will be much easier to
ask for more weapons and when we get
them they they will start working uh for
us faster so
um you know Sophie will
we can't run on the hope you will right
now and today we've got another boost of
this hope
and knowing that the training start
basically means that the conversation
continues president zielinski continues
his trip to Paris and then to Brussels
and he will be giving the same message
don't only stay with Ukraine don't only
stand with us please keep supporting us
but also let's uh all see the way of how
we win the war and this is how we win
the war we need the fighter jets we need
the support we need the weapons to fight
back to defend our land to regain our
sovereignty and to end the war
I need to ask this question because I
know that there will be some people who
are watching at home who will be
wondering this
and they'll be worried about an
escalation with Russia and the
consequences of that if countries like
the UK provide long-range missiles or
fighter jets they're worried about what
it means for security in the UK what
would you say to them
what kind of escalation are we talking
about
so you see I think as of right now the
world has eliminated the nuclear threat
from Russia we have heard it from uh
China and from Indian leaders who are
saying that they are absolutely sure
that Putin would not resort to that we
want to hope that of course but we never
know but what kind of escalation are we
talking we see that Putin cannot push
back and cannot win the war with
Ukrainian Army so he would unlikely go
forward or can start another War so and
in Ukraine he already committed all the
war crimes from the war crimes list we
have suffered all kinds of of Terror and
atrocities uh on and and we know that
there are more to come because he would
not stop unless we stop him so when we
are talking about escalation I always
wonder what people mean by the
escalation I think escalation happened a
year ago and every single day since that
time we are working to
to take him down to make sure that he
would not be threatening the world
anymore and I think we have been very
successful all together in doing that
it's a very powerful answer that you
give and I remember interviewing you and
talking about you know the impact it's
had on children in particular
um and the parents of Ukraine and and
what the kind of thing that they've had
to do and to live through what is the
situation like now in Ukraine you're
talking to us from cave
so I'm running on diesel generator
because there is no electricity and as
of right now more than 50 percent of
energy infrastructure in Ukraine has
been destroyed
so we are going through this probably
hardest winter for all of us since
second world war because when you are
waking up in the morning you go and you
check if you have hit if you have
running water and if you have
electricity and if you all of your
devices are charged and it's almost
never when you have all of it and I can
tell you if we were very scared and
complaining uh that it is hard to sit in
a bomb shelter it can tell you there is
a huge difference when you're sitting in
a bomb shelter when you have heat and
you have electricity and kids can play
on their devices or you can read to them
and there's huge difference when it is
dark and cold and there is no
connectivity or no internet and it's
much harder to sustain much harder to to
still keep it up and say oh it's just a
game because it's not a game when it's
when it's when it's so scary so we have
been doing everything that is in our
powers to uh to make it easier but the
winter has been tough on everyone and I
do hope that we have like maybe a months
and months and a half left uh and and
then it will be easier on on everything
but uh
but it it was indeed there and
especially in the regions that were the
occupied we are not only Energy System
has been destroyed but many things like
like almost everything has been
destroyed I have recently traveled to
Nikolai and Harrison and I have observed
that it's um
uh it's uh it's really a challenge for
for our nation to go through that and
then like to to have those uh wounds
become scars and then to heal those cars
and I still want to say how grateful we
are for all the support and humanitarian
Aid that we are receiving because for
the deoccupied regions they basically
survive on this humanitarian Aid and for
that I'm so grateful on behalf of
Ukrainian people
I have to say like with everything that
you've gone through in the last year and
that you still feel grateful for
something is you know quite remarkable
in itself and thank you as always for
speaking so eloquently thank you
thank you and glory to Ukraine
always incredible uh too and a real
privilege to do interviews with people
speaking to us from places like cave
really living through uh the war in a
way that is very difficult for the rest
of us to really get our heads around but
as you can imagine today has really
focused on that residence visit of
President zelenski the devastating
earthquake however in Turkey in Syria
has dominated the start of the week with
more than 12 000 people now thought to
have died let's take a look back
it's now been two days since this region
was devastated by two major earthquakes
but now scores and scores and scores of
people taking part in this search and
rescue effort we have deployed a large
search and rescue team they will be
deploying to Turkey very soon now Sky
News understands that the Prime Minister
we Shuffle his cabinet later this
morning a lot going on here in Downing
Street this morning now what's happening
is a reshuffle triggered by the sacking
eight days ago of Nadine zahawi the
changes to government I've announced
today will help us deliver on those
promises for the British people to
president zielinski ask Western Nations
to give his country fighter planes
during a surprise visit to London
Russia will lose
and we we really know the victory the
victory will change the world this house
in this country Will Stand United with
the with Ukraine until we ensure the
defeat of Vladimir Putin's unprovoked
unsanctioned aggression and that we will
make sure that Ukraine is not only
Victorious but that we bring peace to
its people
we in this house have a duty to stand on
the shoulders of giants who came before
us and support Ukraine's Fight For
Freedom Liberty and Victory
or you can see it at a show of unity
really both Rishi sunic and kirst armor
in lockstep over Ukraine a little
earlier for labor I spoke to the shadow
of work and pension secretary Jonathan
Ashworth
president zielinski came to address
Parliament today he's asking for jets do
you think that the UK should be sending
Jets to Ukraine well can I just say it
was an absolute privilege to be in
Westminster Hall this afternoon to hear
president zielinski the atmosphere was
electric actually and you could see and
feel the warmth and the support for the
Ukrainian people and the president in
that Hall today I think his request is
entirely reasonable I think it's
important that the government look at
what we can offer and continue to give
Ukrainian people the labor party have
been steadfast in our support for the
Ukrainian people and the government and
their efforts in supporting Ukraine
I'm not a remotely a military expert so
there may well be technical issues
around what is what you know how quickly
you can train people to use the
particular aircrafts but in principle of
course we should be looking at this
investigating what more we can give to
the Ukraine so they can defend
themselves in the face of this
absolutely barbaric unacceptable brutal
Invasion there's the technical aspect
um of course it will take a lot of
training as you say to get the
ukrainians to be able to use the Jets
but there's also the political aspect as
well and we've heard from the Russian
news agency this evening and saying that
deliveries of British fighter jets to
Ukraine would have military and
political consequences for the entire
European uh continent so that coming
from official Russian sources I mean
should we pay attention to that well I
suppose they would say that wouldn't
they because they wouldn't want us to
support Ukraine that we've continued to
support Ukraine throughout this conflict
this absolutely unacceptable Invasion
Russia's invasion you know it's them who
started this Ukraine didn't invade
another country Russia invaded Ukraine
we've supported Ukraine with military
aid and support throughout the period
and it's entirely right and reasonable
that we continue to look at look at what
else we can do and I'm sure the
government is looking at the um as
looking at what what further equipment
what further uh Jets and other equipment
we can send to Ukraine and we should do
that and that's quite right it is it's
it's the big thing though isn't it and
it is worthy of debate you know it's one
thing arming a Ukraine with defensive
weapons they can defend themselves well
this is about them defending themselves
but it's also a should we also be
looking at offensive weapons so things
like Jets we've already delivered tanks
Boris Johnson for example calling for
longer range missiles and artillery well
they're trying to defend themselves and
they're trying to defend themselves in
the face of a totally unacceptable
Invasion From Another Country Russia
they started this and it's quite right
that we look at everything everything
they request so they can defend
themselves and their people I mean we
should look at it everyone would agree
that we should look at it should we
actually do it well I mean that you know
there are logistical questions around
the training and so on so it's quite
right that they are properly explored
but we should look seriously at this
request I think that's the responsible
thing to do to allow Ukraine to defend
to defend itself and defend her people
uh Jeremy corbyn said this week in an
interview that he would prefer to break
a ceasefire rather than send arms to
Ukraine he's previously said that
pouring arms in would prolong and
exaggerate well everybody wants a
ceasefire of course everybody wants to
cease pharah you know I don't think
there's anybody out there other than
Russia who wants us who want who who
says we shouldn't have a ceasefire of
course that's what we want in the end
pouring arms in would prolong and
exaggerate the war well Ukraine has to
defend itself and defend its people who
are being slaughtered and butchered in
the streets of Ukraine because of this
Russian invasion of course we want
Russia to pull out to pull back to to
end this of course we do
but that's not happening at the moment
is it so we've got to do all we can to
allow Ukraine to defend itself and to uh
to fight back
excuse me because it does feel uh like
you know labor having to almost do more
work to convince people that you're on
the side of Ukraine that you're on the
side of NATO I noticed that kistama
mentioned that in prime minister's
questions because yeah
in the last you know a few years people
have questions the labor party's
commitment to labor to Nato uh because
of Jeremy corbyn look the labor party
will always take the defense of the
British people seriously that would be
our number one priority if we were
fortunate enough to form a government
after the next general election and so
we're going to make no apology for
talking about our commitment to Nato and
our commitment to defense that's what
people expect of a potential party my
question was whether you're having to do
more work because of what went before on
Russia well and also on look NATO well I
mean it's obvious there was all kinds of
things that people didn't trust us on in
the 2019 general election and we're
working very hard to rebuild the trust
of the British people you're part of the
Shadow cabinet then weren't you
um
um I've always wanted the the labor
party to I've been in labor party since
I was 15. you know I want the labor
party to succeed but we didn't win that
general election we absolutely smashed
in that general election the electorate
centers a very clear message and we're
rebuilding we're rebuilding and we're
rebuilding a trust with the electorate
but there's a long way to go until the
next general election and we're not
taking anything for granted at all and
now Boris Johnson has become the highest
earning MP he has declared 4.8 million
pounds in earnings this Parliament not
by going we can lend me a few quid
um do you um is that something we should
be relaxed about well declared in the
right way or is there an issue with it I
mean I think there isn't it I mean
there's only a few weeks ago that um
scar you did that brilliant piece of
research pulling all the earnings
together into one database isn't that
top of the leader and people were
shocked people were shocked um because
people think people think there's
something wrong with politics if
politicians can earn these that these
levels of money and there's always
question marks I don't know what his
earnings are I've not looked at I've
just gone off the headline you just told
me now and I've not looked at the detail
of of how he's making that money but you
know I think we've we've got to we've
got to clean up politics we've got to
because people look at all of us and I
think you know what's going on there so
I mean I don't know where he's making
his earnings so I don't really want to
get into the details of things book of
answers
um but you know I think being an MP is a
full-time job it's a certainly a
full-time job for me anyway
and then let's just talk a bit with your
about getting
into the work Force particularly the
over 50s I guess my question is if
you're 55 you've taken early retirement
you enjoy looking after the grandkids a
bit you're enjoying playing the old
round of golf what on Earth would you go
back to work yeah I think that's a
really good question so what we've got
at the moment is we've got employment is
now lower than it was pre the pandemic
and there's more and more people have
been forced out of work some of it is
for sickness it's growing numbers of
people out of work for reasons of mental
ill health depression but many of them
say they would go back to work if they
were given the right levels of support
and you've also got hundreds of
thousands of these older workers the
over 50s who some of them have taken
early retirement and that the government
says oh yes you get off the golf course
quite an insulting approach them
actually but also some of them say that
if there were flexible options if they
were given the right type of help they
would return to the workplace so I put
forward some welfare reform proposals to
deal with the disincentives in the
benefit system the disincentives where
for example if you are sick and you've
been some through something called a
work capability assessment that can be
such a horrible process that it
disincentivizes you from trying work
because you're worried that you'd have
to go through that process again if it
doesn't work out for you so we should we
should reform that we should deal with
the disincentives in the system which
block young parents often women
shouldn't be it tends to be women but
young parents when going into work
because of the way the child care
element of Universal Credit operates we
should deal with that and I've put
forward proposals on that and we should
give the over 50s older workers more
support through the job center if they
want it more help finding a flexible
work option because they could be doing
looking after their grandkids they're
probably also by the way caring for a
loved one perhaps even a mum or a dad
because there's no social care provision
but they might be tempted back if they
could find a flexible job that allows
them to balance all these different
elements in their life so these are the
sort of welfare reforms that we and the
labor party are proposing because we
want to get this country back to work I
don't want to write anybody often people
have been written off at the moment okay
thank you very much thank you
Jonathan Ashworth out there well let's
talk to you Sam coach shall we we're
just talking there about people who
don't work hard enough well we're not
exactly winding down for half time in
Westminster are we it's been a funny
couple of days Sophie I think we were
expecting not not a particularly active
uh period of time before recess which is
next week and yet today we saw the
unexpected visit of President zielinski
and all MPS and peers hearing from him
in the houses of Parliament there you
have the picture of him on the steps of
Westminster Hall the beautiful light
streaming through Saint Stephen's porch
onto the speech as he gave it and then
all of the sort of almost like a state
visit that we had in a day completely
unexpectedly and then yesterday we had a
reshuffle we weren't expecting that
either and that surprised all of us and
had quite unexpected unexpected places
yeah let's talk about the reshuffle
shall we because it feels like for me
reshuffles are a big moment to kind of
reset
um and yet this was quite techy right
like reorganization reorganizing
Whitehall departments just 18 months
away from an election I mean some people
are saying that it's classic Rishi sudak
so Richardson had a problem to deal with
the problem that he needed to solve was
that he sacked natim zahawi for his tax
Affairs and the way that he dealt with
questions about his tax about nine days
ago and needed to fill the job of
conservative party chair and he did that
with an appointment of a individual MP
called Greg Heavens he's a West London
MP and a new Deputy called Lee Anderson
which has caused some controversy and
all that's well and good but the big
thing he did yesterday was to lift up
the Bonnet of government and do a hell
of a lot of tinkering he moved four
different government departments around
basically created new four new Whitehall
departments he stripped out the energy
brief from the business department put
that with climate change in the
Standalone department and put Grand
Chaps in charge of that he took the
business briefly added the trade uh
elements of that and put kemi badenoff
in charge of that he brought somebody
else new into cabinet Lucy Fraser she's
now in charge of culture media and Sport
which which takes that department back
to something it was five also years ago
and created a new department for Science
and Innovation and digital and put
Michelle Donald who ended up being his
second choice for that department uh in
charge of that now
the problem with all of that Sophie is
it's the kind of thing you do when
you're a new government when you've just
come in because every time you
reorganize Whitehall it's months of
people swapping chairs and spending
money and reorganizing a brass place it
doesn't deliver quickly and a lot of
people are asking what was the gain in
the short term some people ask about the
political Mouse I guess of Richard Cena
because he a bit naive
um I think it's too early to call him
naive I think the thing he's got to
prove is that he's not just you know
indecisive political souffle is it is it
word just sort of technocratic and uh
and managerial without being able to
inspire people to convince people to do
what Boris Johnson did well if Boris
Johnson wasn't good at managing he
certainly was good at taking people on a
journey the question is can Richardson
act do the same they do feel like very
different politicians don't they sound
always interesting to hear at your take
think of him thanks very much for being
on the program this evening
uh well that was Sam always on the
program real regular and another chance
for a regular feature of our program we
can take a closer look at a question to
the prime minister at pmqs that really
caught our eye and today is this one
Big Brother watch recently released a
report into unaccountable government
bodies such as the counter
disinformation unit the rapid response
unit and the British Army's 77th Brigade
we're seeing huge sways of public money
being spent recording political a
descent on social media under the guise
of tackling this information politicians
including myself the leader of the
opposition academics activists and
journalists and even members of public
have been subjected to monitoring by
White Hall officials this at the same
time as we're waiting for the reporting
of the Pitchford inquiry into
questionable State surveillance on
campaigns like the Stephen Lawrence
campaign so can the Prime Minister tell
us how much public money is spent on
these units and what they think is a
justifiable thing to do in our democracy
to spend public money in this manner and
could you also update the house on the
progress of the Pitchford inquiry prime
minister well Mr Speaker I have to get
back to the honorable lady on the pigeon
inquiry and indeed to give her an exact
figure but in general uh I think
certainly iron on this side of the house
believe very strongly in free speech and
we'll make sure that we continue to
protect it wherever a weekend
now of course usually npmq is the
question and doesn't get a chance to
respond to the piano's answer but here
it's very different here they do and
that question whoops I'm going to fall
over my chat there that question was
from labors Bell Riviera Addy the MP for
streatham who joins us now thanks very
much for being on the program firstly
just to explain what your question was
all about people who may not have been
following this story well Big Brother
watch recently put out a report on
various government units that were
initially targeted at disinformation
differently during the pandemic loads of
things which were forced being put out
and the government said they wanted to
look into this what we found however is
that they're again going through the
social media accounts of of members of
parliament activists campaigners
academics all of these things that
various Freedom of Information requests
put in by myself and others have
revealed this is there a problem if it's
your public social media postings no it
shouldn't really be a problem if it's my
public social media postings but begs
the question why are they looking into
it firstly it's public secondly why is
so much of time from Whitehall when we
have a whole host of problems in this
country being spent looking at my public
information it doesn't make any sense
and then passing comment
um in in some way putting it in
particular boxes as to what I've said
about different things why is it being
done to lead over opposition why is it
being done to conservative MPS who have
expressed uh some sort of dissent from
from the from their party why why is
that happening if it's only happening to
people that say things against the
government and there's clearly an issue
do you think that it does show perhaps
that you know some in the establishment
see certain perspectives as dangerous
thinking about perspectives from the
left in particular I guess possibly but
we're also talking about conservative
MPS these are some of their own
um comrades if you want to call them who
are members of their party who just
don't agree with them at that point in
time what exactly is the issue why
should we be carrying out surveillance
on them why you know is so much of
public money being put into it and this
is obviously whilst we wait for this
Pitchford inquiry and the reason why I
linked it to that is because that's
another point in time where again
members of parliament and campaigns were
were looked into by another emanation of
the state this this was the police
actually it was a lot of undercover
policing
um and gathering information on people
for reasons which don't seem to make
much sense what did you make of the
prime minister's response then he didn't
really respond did he that he said that
there's he believes in the right to
freedom of speech but the right to
freedom of speech uh is is is important
but if I have the right to freedom of
speech why are you gathering information
on it it doesn't make any sense and it's
a massive waste of public funds
especially when we find that actually
you're involving the police you're
involving the military you're involving
civil servants and you're also trying to
use that information to to gauge public
opinion as to what uh what the views are
on the government that's not a use of
public resources if if the conservative
party want to do that the conservative
party should do that they shouldn't be
using government resources to do it I'm
Keen well I've got you to ask your view
on the other big story we've been
covering today president zielinski
talking to MPS he's asking for fighter
jets should we give them to Ukraine I
think um you know it it was really
amazing to hear president zelinski speak
and we need to do everything that we can
to support Ukraine against Russia's
aggression and exactly what we do
because of the sensitivities around what
how it may bring us into the War I
suppose is something that needs to be
discussed but we should have been some
people who've said Jeremy Corbin for
example the pouring arms in could
prolong the war
I I mean I mean we just want we just
want the war to come to to an end as
soon as possible but we really need to
be doing everything we can to support
Ukraine and that includes uh supporting
those from Ukraine that have had to flee
uh come to the UK I'm really
disappointed in how the government has
been treating Ukrainian refugees we've
heard about people having to go back
we've heard about people not um getting
the support that they need here that's
just not good enough okay thanks very
much for being on the program we are out
of time and thanks very much that is it
for the take we went actually back at
next week we're having a little half
term uh break but Sophia Ridge on Sunday
is on this Sunday Sky News 8 30 a.m so
I'll see you then Sky News at 10 is up
next
foreign
[Music]